the periodic table of elements is
complete there are no gaps and there
were gaps in it up until as late as the
1950s one of the last elements to be
discovered was technum named Tech you
know what the definition of tech is
human made wow that's why technology is
we made it it's not in nature tech means
artificial human-made that element
doesn't exist in nature so we created it
nature makes elements up to 94 we have
created elements beyond that up to 118
the number is the amount of protons in
the number of protons correct so it's
like we have one with eight we have one
with 10 but we can't find the one with
nine we find the one with nine that's
how you know that there's a gap cuz it's
a discrete number of protons in the
nucleus of these atoms so yeah there's
gaps above 118 but not in the main table
that you saw hanging in the front of
your chemistry class